[Musique]
bonjour ravi de retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7 fit culture musique
cirque ou encore pentures de nombreux
rendez-vous vous attendent tout de suite
le sommaire lancement de saison pour la
batterie de guyancourt le lieu culturel
à présenter sa programmation pour le
trimestre à venir et jazz piano hip hop
une dizaine d'artistes sont à l'affiché
jusqu'en décembre
stéphane ridard le chargé de
programmation nous présentera les temps
forts les débuts du cirque aux états
unis raconté dans une comédie musicale
un spectacle original à découvrir très
prochainement à versailles monsieur
barnum le rêve d'un cirque se veut être
un hymne à la différence nous avons
assisté à la répétition générale
habré dans le bretonneux près de 60 des
oeuvres ont investi la maison de covile
c'est dans le cadre de la biennale de la
teinture jusqu'au 20 octobre le public
pourra voter pour son oeuvre préférée
c'est au son de la folk que la batterie
de guyancourt a présenté à sa
programmation jusqu'en décembre et vous
allez voir tous les styles sont réunis
pour ce dernier trimestre 2010 9
[Musique]
stefan ried à bonjour bonjour vous êtes
chargé de programmation à la batterie de
guyancourt alors la saison a été lancée
avant de parler bien sûr des temps forts
de la programmation du trimestre à venir
est ce que vous pouvez nous parler
brièvement de ce lieu on se trouve alors
la batterie du encore s'appelle la
batterie ce qui est une ancienne
batterie militaire tous tous efforts qui
étaient autour de paris pour protéger
paris 10 1810 est donc celui est devenu
un équipement culturel
donc on a inauguré la partie du fort
meade 2007 et la partie école qui a été
inauguré un petit peu plus tard l'école
de musique a rejoint le pôle musique en
novembre 2000
d'ici je n'ai pas de bêtises donc tout
l'équipement on va dire est fonctionnel
depuis 2011
alors un lieu évidemment entièrement
dédié à la musique pour la présentation
de saison vous avez choisi de mettre en
avant deux groupes le groupe mountain
fire excusé pour vendre exemple le
fleuriste man alors pourquoi ces deux
groupes ils ont un lien j'imagine avec
avec la batterie sont déjà venus ici
alors en effet ils ont un lien avec la
batterie c'est que ces deux groupes sont
déjà venus répéter dans nos studios de
répétition que si on a aussi on parlait
de pôle musique le bar restaurant les
studios de répétition donc ce sont des
musiciens du territoire puisque pour
olivier qui est le leader de forrest man
qui est un projet solo en fait olivier
du côté de rambouillet et même tarif
ailleurs le groupe ils sont vraiment sur
rambouillet sont venus d'ailleurs par
nos collègues de l'usiné à chapeaux et
donc le lien c'est que ces personnes ont
répété dans les studios de la batterie
nous on sollicite également pour des
résidences donc
mountain fire viendra au mois de
décembre fait un travail de résidence
pendant trois jours dans la salle 2
deux spectacles
m
et puis on avait envie de défendre aussi
cette esthétique folk le boisé et
peut-être parce qu'ils sont du côté de
rambouillet donc les bourses à que voilà
bien les grands espaces les forêts et
donc qu'on leur a proposé d'ouvrir
entre guillemets la saison puisque nous
on fonctionne au trimestre donc pour la
petite présentation de prime est de
faire un petit show case dans le bar
restaurant pour le trimestre à venir
jacques les moments forts on va terminer
avec les generation qui sont
actuellement la résidence chez nous
préparer leur tournée ils feront
d'ailleurs un olympia jour en mars que
joueront le 14 décembre et samedi 14
décembre à la batterie dans la salle
debout on accueillera également un
projet on va dire qu'il entre le jazz et
la musique cubaine qui aurait pu être
présentée dans notre éditorial mais on a
fait le choix de présenter cet artiste
dans la salle debout c'est roberto
fonseca qu un cubain qui d'ailleurs fera
la salle pleyel à paris au mois de mars
[Musique]
et puis peut-être aussi un groupe à
découvrir absolument sur scène c'est un
groupe qui s'appelle voodoo game ce sont
des lieux ils sont basés à lyon avec un
chanteur togolais
peter solo qui est vraiment voilà un
chanteur assez charismatique et qui est
dans la famille de ce qu'on appelle
l'afrobeat afro funk
voilà donc musique à ces métis et voilà
ça ce sera le 9 novembre
et puis un rendez-vous aussi original
c'est le 30 novembre les studios dont du
coeur parce que le principe est original
coup pour rentrer pour voir l'artiste en
fait il faut amener un jouet en c'est
bien ça oui tout à fait alors ça c'est
parce qu on avait programmé
elmer food beat les nantais qui ont
monté une opération il ya une trentaine
d'années qui s'appelle toujours pas ce
que ça existe toujours les rockeurs ont
du coeur
donc on
quand ils sont passés au mois de mai
j'aurais posé la question de savoir si
on pouvait utiliser le nom on a un petit
peu transformés c'est devenu les studios
ont du coeur puisque c'est porté par mes
collègues des studios gillet christophe
est donc en effet le principe c'est
comme pour les rockeurs ont du coeur
c'est à dire qu'on a tous que de payer
un billet d'entrée on demande aux gens
de voir acheter un jouet qui sera donc
distribué par en collaboration avec le
cm2 la ville de guyancourt
via une association aux familles
justement pour que tous les enfants qui
se passer un noël agréable puis bien sûr
toutes ses dates on peut retrouver sur
votre site internet réservé si les voilà
tout à fait pour avoir un peu plus de
détails parce que c'est vrai que c'est
toujours compliqué d'être synthétique
pour présenter des musiciens le mieux
c'est de venir les voir en concert
plutôt que voilà que deux que d'essayer
d'en parler c'est de venir les écouter
dans les salles de spectacle merci
stéphane ridard je rappelle que vous
êtes le chargé de la programmation à la
batterie de guyancourt
à
c'est un spectacle un peu particulier
que vous allez à présent découvrir le
cirque musical est une troupe de 40
artistes qui racontent sous un chapiteau
et l'histoire de phinéas taylor barnum
qui n'est autre que le créateur du
cirque moderne aux états unis ce projet
est né dans les yvelines à versailles et
nous avons pu suivre leur répétition
générale ils sont 25 sur scène à danser
chanter et déclamer ses bénévoles font
partie de l'association le cirque
musical
leur projet est réinterprété sous forme
de comédie musicale l'histoire de
phinéas taylor barnum le créateur du
cirque moderne aux états unis c'est en
voyant le film the west show man avec
tout jackman que le président de
l'association versaillaise a décidé de
lancer ce projet certains disent que
c'était un gredin et qu' il s'est servi
beaucoup de gens d'autres retiendront
plutôt que c'était quelqu'un qui avait
un grand coeur et qui s'est du coup
inspiré de ces personnes là et qui leur
a donné un lieu pour s'exprimer et donc
jeu on a retenu cette histoire vision
d'accueil
cette vision de partage sur une scène
autour d'un show il s'agit de la
première comédie musicale sous chapiteau
avec les personnes en coulisses cette
troupe d'amateurs et de semi
professionnel est composé d'une
quarantaine de bénévoles
au coeur de cette aventure artistique la
sublimation des différences
l'interprète de la chanson this is me
donc une chanson qui parle vraiment de
blessure c'est la voilà quand les si la
femme à barbe se fait rejeter de la
troupe
et d'ailleurs ça me touche énormément
fait de travailler texte de vraiment de
ça en excellent exercice de théâtre
d'aller rechercher ses propres blessé en
fait c'est propre ça prend entre ça et
et après douala d'être un peu écorché
vif en fait certaines 17 dates sont
programmées pour cette tournée d'automne
six représentations auront lieu à
versailles à partir du 19 octobre
[Musique]
nouveau rendez vous dans ce set 8
culture à chaque semaine les
responsables des lieux culturels nous
présente un spectacle coup de coeur et
direction le théâtre de san quentin en
yvelines avec son directeur lionel masse
et à les 15 et 16 octobre il y à un
spectacle qu'elle nous tenons tout
particulièrement pour deux raisons la
première raison c'est que le metteur en
scène où le concepteur du projet est un
artiste qui s'appelle aurélien bory et
que l'on suit à la scène nationale de
saint quentin en yvelines depuis des
années et la deuxième raison qui nous
touche c'est que il est assez rare que
des artistes face le portrait d'autres
artistes et dans l'occurrence aurélien
bory fait le portrait de stéphanie
fuster qui est une danseuse flamenca
françaises sont assez rares les dans
seulement un cas française qui l ont
fait leur profession
elle est allée à prendre pendant des
années le flamenco a sévi et c'est
vraiment immergé dans cette culture là
elle est sur scène c'est à dire c'est
aurélien bory fait le portrait de
l'artiste de la danse ce qui est sur
scène remarquable danseuse que l'on voit
à l'oeuvre et qui est accompagné de
musiciens sévillan guitaristes chanteurs
et chanteuses la scénographie comme dans
tous les projets de règne un gorille est
absolument
voilà troublante et facilement
[Musique]
la ville de voisins-le-bretonneux a
lancé le 5 octobre s'habiller nal de la
peinture jusqu'au dimanche mme en
octobre le public pourra découvrir tous
les après midi à la maison de covile
près de 70 euros s'ils variés 44
artistes pas entre ont participé à cette
exposition et les visiteurs pourront
donner leur préférence un prix du public
sera remis à l'issue de l'exposition
nous avons beaucoup beaucoup de nouveaux
artistes cette année il ya c'est la
deuxième année que nous nous devons
faire une sélection tellement il y à des
artistes qui veulent venir dans cette
belle maison il ya assez peu
d'aquarelles cette année alors que
certaines années vous avez vous aviez
beaucoup beaucoup d'aquarelle oui nous
avons du dessin qui s'apparente quasi
elle à la bande dessinée nous avons là
évidemment du pastel de l'huile de la
linogravure il me semble des techniques
mixtes et très variée autres billets n'a
cette fois ci c'est des beaux-arts à
rambouillet il s'agit de la deuxième
édition organisée par l'association
rambouillet arrêt partagent près de 170
oeuvres sont exposées jusqu'au 20
octobre
direction le cinéma les yeux d'elsa à
saint cyr l'école qui propose le samedi
19 octobre une soirée admis nation
trois films d'animation japonais seront
à diffuser de 16 heures à 23 heures
comme tous les ans au mois d'octobre on
fait des focus sur le cinéma d'animation
et cette année on a décidé de faire un
focus sur le cinéma d'animation japonais
comme on le fait très souvent ou parce
qu'en plus il ya des films extrêmement
importants qui sont sortis les six
derniers mois et on n'avait pas eu
l'occasion de les passer donc vous allez
pouvoir éventuellement les revoir
éventuellement les rattraper on va vous
diffuser pendant une toute une partie du
mois d'octobre les films le mystère des
pingouins
wonderland le royaume sans pluie et les
enfants de la mer avec en particulier le
samedi 19 octobre une soirée après midi
soirée animation qui commence à ses
heures et qui finira à 23h avec les
trois films que je viens de citer
comme chaque semaine nous vous donnons
quelques idées de sorties à saint
quentin en yvelines le 15 octobre le
prisme à elancourt accueillera la pièce
est ce que j'ai une gueule d'arletty
autre ambiance à la merise attrape avec
govrache et nice kelly pour une soirée
slam
si vous êtes du côté de la ferme du
manet à montigny le bretonneux il y aura
du théâtre avec une pièce mise en scène
par mathilda may ça s'appelle le
banquier et puis c'est une soirée un
métal qui vous attend le samedi 19
octobre à l'estaminet à magny les
hameaux
au programme pas moins de huit groupes
voici cette sélection en images et en
musique
[Musique]
maeder
à
vivant météo maintenance et c'est le
cinéma voit pas chez moi frère je vis
oui je me souviens du bout de la table
comme da fragments d'éternité
c'est noël j'ai quatre ans je suis le
plus jeune de la famille à l'autre bout
en face de moi mon arrière grand mère
est figée elle n'entend plus que des
yeux et semble sourire sans béquilles
chapitre 1 appelle moi aussi j'ai fait
avec marine pour un agent dérogerait
j'allège l'enclume château de méry nsa
mars à paris
[Musique]
ce que dément le monde du vin
et on termine avec un dernier concert le
chanteur miossec sera sur la scène de la
barbacane c'est aden au rendez vous
jeudi 17 octobre à 20h45 pour découvrir
son onzième album les rescapés
les surveillons au sol
son
passer de 3
tous
nous sommes
m
kp
2 voilà c'est la fin de ses 7,8 culture
on se retrouve mardi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro à très bientôt
[Musique]